hello ladies and gentlemen I'm Ryan
right so today's Thanksgiving before I
get into this video for Star Wars The
Force awakens extended TV spot with new
footage Thanksgiving special I wanted to
say thank you guys for a wonderful year
first year of the real rejects we ended
with only 1,200 followers second year
around 75,000 the years not even over
yet and we're almost at 300,000 a lot of
times people compare my channel to like
other channels and be like well they're
getting higher subs than you but I
really don't give a [ __ ] because I care
about the ones who are already
subscribed to the channel not so much
about gathering bigger numbers and
gathering new subs but I really care
about the ones who are already
subscribed and I try to do my best to
tend to you guys so thank you so much I
got a bunch of requests for this the
best way to say thank you is by filming
a video on Thanksgiving to this anyway
Star Wars The Force awakens extended TV
spot no dark meat
like the imperial market all teams
merci we all me too
yeah
it just keeps getting better and better
I'm not watching all the TV spots I'm
not watching every single trailer that
drops because I don't want too much to
be ruined for me that was awesome I love
the opening of the trailer how it
started off a Darth Vader song I hope
they use that song in some way in the
actual movie you know I gotta say man
like I don't know if this is gonna be
the best Star Wars but this looks like
the best looking Star Wars film the
color schemes of everything seems so
beautiful like the cinematography is
just pure excellence I don't know who
that guy was at the beginning where he
was like crying and kylo Ren was like
doing something to him but wow that
looks emotional as [ __ ] kylo Ren was
probably deleting all the pornographic
images that the guy was able to absorb
over the years out of his mind
which makes sense why he's freaking out
this movies like right around the corner
I mean we've been waiting for this movie
for so [ __ ] long years and years of
news and production stuff I can't
believe it's finally here that it's
coming out in just a couple weeks I
already got three different showings to
this movie like I got one on Thursday
night Friday night and then an IMAX
screening on like Tuesday night I think
I am so stoked for this film this is
called star wars and this feels like a
galaxy war I love that vibe you know
like Empire Strikes Back really had that
vibe of Star Wars and I feel like we
have a war going on here looks so
[ __ ] epic
I love the shots of some of our classic
characters being in the battlefield like
Han Solo and Chewie
I like seeing that affirmation happened
because it's better than just like is
Han Solo gonna make an appearance is
your share some dialogue or we're gonna
actually see him suing some lasers and
stuff we're gonna see him shooting some
lasers and I think this trailer had the
most screaming I've seen out of all the
Star Wars trailers a lot of oh man these
trailers are just doing the perfect
teases you know it's like they're
establishing a villain without giving
too much away but you can tell he's a
scary menacing [ __ ] and then you
got new heroes you got old heroes coming
together I really like it I love how
they're not
Luke Skywalker that is so cool that
they're doing jju you know what you're
doing with the marketing man like you
really know what you're doing anyway
guys thanks for sending that my way
today if you're new to the channel you
can click this button above my head and
subscribe to the Rio rejects become a
reject today once again I want to say
thank you it's been a wonderful [ __ ]
year the years still not over I got big
plans for 2016 I got a lot of things in
mind more than just reaction reviews of
course there's gonna be more sketches
now we got one in the pipeline for
Christmas there's so much we have
planned that we want to show you guys we
want to show more of our creative skills
this time around don't worry the
reaction reviews discussions are still
going to be around but I wanted to say
thank you as without you guys definitely
wouldn't be here and most importantly I
know you guys are grateful for me I'm
grateful for me as a matter of fact you
guys want to be subscribed if it wasn't
for me existing in the first place so
you're welcome
really this this Thanksgiving thing
should just be about me and nothing
about you